[Music]
hello i'm angelique polk i'm an
instructor at the department of
neurology at mass general hospital in
boston massachusetts in the u.s
and i want to thank the organizers of
the neuroscience virtual event which is
a part of the nih brain initiative human
neuroscience and cross-cutting impact of
scientific collaboration for this
opportunity to discuss this work which
in this particular case
i'm going to try to convince you that
high resolution or high spatial
resolution electrodes can improve our
understanding of the human brain
understanding of cognition and
neurological pathologies
because microelectrodes are
and have been used for the past 30 years
to uncover secrets of the brain they've
been you know instrumental in
understanding aspects of cognition and
as well as neural pathologies and here's
a few examples of the different kinds of
electrodes uh in the lower left portion
of the slide
you see a laminar array which is a type
of looks somewhat like a thumbtack but
it actually has individual contacts that
are 100 microelectric contacts that are
150 microns apart from each other
there's also the well-known neural port
array which is
also called a utah array which has 96
microelectrodes to sample single neuron
activity it sucks freed and his uh a
large team of collaborators have
actually been using microwires which are
at the end of clinical depth electrodes
to a great effect to understand uh
cognition and and pathology there's also
different types of electrodes that are
microgrids and these particular
electrodes are incredibly powerful
in that
they have been
instrumental in understanding aspects of
cognition as well as understanding
aspects of say epilepsy
it's important that you know these
particular microelectrodes have you know
resulted in these advances of
understanding normal and abnormal
physiology in the human brain and has
already led to clinical advances in
decoding handwriting in patients with
severe neurological injuries or in
better understanding seizures in
patients with epilepsy
so really these devices are powerful and
incredible
in the hands of clinicians and
researchers to understand these these
important questions but the technology
isn't limited that most of these
electrodes are made of metal or a very
fine wire
and therefore there's aspects that you
know in terms of customization that
they're limited by also in the
manufacturer and also in in terms of
their spatial resolution
so with regard to that there have been
huge advances in the past really decade
of you know moving you know particularly
in the materials and sciences
that you know would allow us to move
from 150 micron spatial sampling to a
220 to 50 micron contact contact spacing
with improvements in customization
and these latest technologies are what
i'm going to be talking about today
particularly two different kinds that
i'll be highlighting but to give you a
sense of the scale that i'm talking
about here is a cut out view of a
hemisphere of a human brain there's the
temporal lobe and the frontal lobe here
and as we zoom in what i'm going to
actually sort of highlight is that there
are you know clinical leads which are
these larger blue bands that you
actually get
notice here
but closer in is these microelectrodes
that i just discussed in the previous
slide
the micro contacts here are highlighted
as yellow the blue bands are the larger
sort of um
clinical leaves that are normally used
for understanding or are sampling
seizure onset of zones and epilepsy and
then the little tiny cells that you see
in there are actually the neurons
reconstructed to scale to give you a
sense of scale that the scale of
understanding cells and brain cells is
much smaller than certainly the clinical
leads and even smaller relative to
current microelectrode technologies what
you also see in the middle of that
figure there are neural pixels which is
one of the technologies that i'll be
discussing today
that affords us that much closer sort of
recording and spatial mapping relative
to single neurons in the brain
and
what we're finding and you know both us
as as a large consortium team as well as
other
teams in the you know across the world
is that using the high resolution
recordings in human neurophysiology
could provide novel and important
insights into normal circuits how these
circuits participate in cognition and
behavior and how these circuits are
impaired in pathology
so the point of my talk today
is to lay out five stories there's five
studies where we actually
were able to demonstrate these kinds of
um aspects of of how microelectrodes can
actually improve what we understand of
the human brain particularly
and what's amazing is that these
particular stories have actually come
out in the past year and so we were able
to uh
identify and understand what's going on
with the microscope activity using such
you know great technologies
what do i mean by the different types of
uh advances and technology well
one of the technologies i wanted to
highlight is a thin film recording so
these are thin film electrodes which
essentially
are so thin they're usually between
seven and and 15 microns thick in terms
of the material they can actually lay on
the surface of the cortex
and can be essentially you know quote
unquote printed in a way just so you can
actually customize the design and shape
so you actually see on the right side
two different examples of thin film
electrodes where on the top you actually
have 128 contacts made of pdot pss which
is a type of material that allows you
for low impedance and high resolution
recordings
and then on the bottom you actually see
a design for an electrode that has a
1024 contacts to be able to record
neural activity across the surface of
the human brain these contacts could
also be made of platinum nanorod
which is in itself uh low impedance but
also allows for
microstimulation you know at the at the
contacts as well
and these electrodes have been uh used
by us and then various other groups to
be able to sort of understand you know
microscope dynamics and how it
propagates across the surface of the
brain
the other type of electrode i'm going to
highlight is the neural pixels neural
pixels has taken the world by storm to
the neuroscience world by storm has been
used to great effect in non-human
primates and and
rodents to be able to understand
underlying neural dynamics
so with regard to that
um
so to give you a sense of scale of these
uh why microelectrodes are actually can
sample uh information that much better
relative to single electrodes i'm going
to actually show you a activity
represented as simulated activity
represented by a single electrode and
the waveforms that are shown up for you
know two different neurons on a single
contact compared to you know when it
actually is represented on on the
microelectrodes on a neuropixel
array in this this video what you'll see
is that there are uh activity
represented by as the spikes or action
potentials on the on the left and this
particular activity is pretty hard to
tell what's going on you know if you're
just recording from a single cell as
opposed to on the neural pixels array
you have an address you have a spatial
map that is actually being represented
across multiple contacts across the the
neural pixel array that you know
this emphasizes that we can identify any
single cells and their substrates in
terms of
cognition and pathophysiology
with regard to that
to even further illustrate this point
when you have more than just a single
cell
you can actually observe that there are
multiple you know reasons why
microelectric sampling and high
resolution sampling
helps
standing
in understanding neural dynamics such as
you know in this case i'm actually
illustrating excitatory inhibitory cells
and their ongoing dynamics can be wildly
you know fireworks effect
enabling but they can't necessarily be
sampled using low resolution electrodes
so between the neural pixels array and
the high resolution thin film arrays on
the top of the surface of the cortex we
can start to parse out what each of
these cells are doing during you know
specific you know important behavioral
functions um in the course of of any
type of cognition or in the case of
epilepsy or tumor
but i will would like to illustrate and
highlight especially the
teamwork that is involved in making this
possible to be able to you know
understand human uh brain activity first
off i would like to mention that shady
daya who has been a major role in
in making these kinds of thin film
electrodes or microelectrodes available
for
us and and several other groups and he's
been spearheading you know the
development of thousands of
electro type of microelectrodes in this
domain that has allowed us to ask some
pretty amazing questions i'd also thank
a large team and especially imac which
is uh you know and led by
um uh in this this effort by brewing
duda to move uh a lot pretty amazing
chip technologies and silicon
technologies into the neural pixel array
for the use you know by you know various
other collaborators you can see on the
right but also by a number of different
individuals across the country
and of course all this would not be
possible without the help and hard work
of the clinicians because translating
these devices for use in the operating
room whether the neural pixels probe or
the thin film electrodes have required
years
and months of development of a workflow
that emphasizes patient safety and
regulation requirements you know in the
cash lab we've been led by both sydney
cash and the angling ii to make this
this work possible as well as the aid of
a number of different clinicians that in
the clinical team to you know
to make these recordings you know even
happening in the upper operating room
particularly since the operating room
and recording neural activity in the
operating room provides an amazing
opportunity to be able to
understand
what is going on with human physiology
and in the operating room itself it
actually it can be explored human
physiology can be explored in a safe and
ethically responsible fashion but it
comes with challenges and in that that
particular domain
we have found that it is important to
realize that there are both clinical
considerations sterilization validation
clinical workflow and especially patient
safety as well as scaling considerations
when moving these particular devices
that have been used in the um in basic
neuroscience domain into the into the
human
brain
but with all of these considerations in
mind
i'd like to
sort of convey or communicate the kinds
of
advances or
improvements and understanding of the
human brain that we've been able to
pursue using these microelectrodes and
especially the neural pixels and then
film microelectrodes to understand
different dynamics and different uh
settings
with regard to neuropixel it was a
pretty amazing moment to be able to
record neural activity using the neural
pixel array because as i tried to
communicate in the earlier videos
you'll see that you can actually follow
and identify individual cells on a very
fine scale using these high spatial
resolution electrodes working with the
fantastic team we're able to identify
that there are diverse waveforms that
could be tracked through time
during the
duration of the recording
and these waveforms represented in this
slide
you know it gives just a snippet of this
under this this wide you know
and you know multifaceted array of
different types of cell types that we
may be able to uncover just through the
use of these these types of electrodes
in one particular case we were able to
report 202 single cells
at once to be able to identify you know
what exactly is going on in different
areas of the cortex you know along the
different layers of the cortex and this
already has has uncovered you know
different aspects of the fact that
across the you know the different cases
we're able to
observe a wide ranging diversity of
waveforms and shapes
which allows us to have you know
individual cell identity but also sell
some interactions that we would not be
been able to uncover without this kind
of high spatial resolution
so future data collection and analyses
of the neural pixels data could reveal a
treasure trove of cell to cell
interactions and improve the
understanding of cell activity within
the cortical column itself
and in that regard
the neural pixels
alone has enabled improved sampling of
the voltages so we can observe a wide
variety of cell types
which is a pretty much a launching
ground
pad for a massive number of studies
which we hope will uncover you know
secrets essentially the human brain
but one thing i actually want to sort of
pivot on here is that we have some
amazing uh data that's you know building
not from us from other groups of using
neural pixels to understand spiking
activity the microscope recordings and
themselves are also
revealing novel neurophysiological
events in the human brain that we would
not have otherwise been able to uncover
without you know these devices
so we uh one particular paper that we
publish is demonstrating that we
actually found we could identify and see
these unitary events
that would propagate across the
microelectrodes using the thin film
surface electrodes
and we actually see that these unitary
events would be repeated they can be
clustered they just happen to be slower
or longer in duration compared to spikes
or single action potentials
so the question is what exactly are
these things well
we
couldn't quite answer that kind of
question in the human brain but we could
also demonstrate that these these
things these events type two and three
events
were
physiological they acted like they you
know units except for they were just
somewhat slower they varied with direct
electrical stimulation they were
suppressed with intravenous introduction
of pro-convulsive medication and cold
saline
they were present
largely in the upper layers of the
cortex in the layer one through three
areas and they actually seem to you know
be shown in a number of other different
types of electrodes
and because we were able to observe
these in so many different cases
uh we were asked we're starting to ask
the question of what exactly they are
because one you know aspect that was
pretty exciting
was the fact that they varied with a
particular word and actually um this
task developed by dan cleary and eric
hallgren
uh there was a particular task where you
could actually present the participant
with a real word a nonsense syllable or
a white noise kind of kind of sound
and what was interesting is these events
increase significantly relative to the
real word versus the other other sounds
already indicating to us that there is a
physiological correlate or of what these
these particular events are
and the ongoing investigation will be
then to
examine these events relative to
different sort of calcium dynamics or
gender drug action potentials test are
we able to sample
high resolution information that is
beyond just the single action potential
spikes produced around the cell body
are these particularly new novel events
you know allow us to be able to look at
you know cell center cell cell
interactions or dendritic action um you
know you know calcium waves that we
otherwise would not have been able to
sample without microelectrodes
so of course this already opens up an
entire another new investigation just
like how the neuropixels array did but
the thin film electrodes you know allows
us to also sample other kinds of like
mechanisms and
aspects of of uh neurodynamics that we
otherwise would not have been able to
uncover including the detailing the
mechanisms underlying stimulation
and what do i mean by that well we have
we you know use their
stimulation in terms of
therapy such as in deep brain
stimulation or when they be able to you
know treat or understand what's going on
in the brain such as with diagnosis or
on the treatment of tumor being able to
remove uh tumor area while leaving
behind functional brain area regions
such as mapping language and motor
functional regions during interoperative
recordings
and in this particular example in the
figure on the left you see sort of two
long
sticks these are bipolar stimulators
that can be used and moved by hand by
the neurosurgeon and and then they
stimulate in certain areas to be able to
either arrest or change the language um
sort of of the awake patient to be able
to understand where where in the brain
it is functional
this particular procedure is is
you know consistently done and
which uh as a way to identify areas to
resect and working with lulu
malola at moriero we want to understand
what's going on in the microscale level
what is going on in the single neuron or
local level using these microelectrodes
especially the thin film microelectrodes
so what she was able to do which is
fantastic is
use deep lab cut a computer vision
program that would allow you to actually
map
and identify the location of the
stimulant electrode relative to the
micro electrode
and
using this this program she was able to
then you know identify the stimulation
locations relative to uh the
microelectric recording so what you're
going to see here is that you know
basically to be able to track the
stimulation and be able to
map it relative to the
local microscale activity
fused
we were able to
as you can see in this big black bar
that's when stimulation is happening
what happens a few seconds later is
these large sort of
sort of waves or spikes that would
actually happen in the micro electric
recordings
in this particular case you you can
actually you know observe that you know
it actually varies when the stimulation
location moves around to the different
locations but in this particular dynamic
you you can
observe something that's a little bit
different that cannot be necessary you
know we could not find on the clinical
leads
and what they are
are these big propagating waves
happening about you know one to two
seconds after stimulation
and because we're recording with
microelectrodes we can then take a look
to take a look at the um underlying
activity and the dynamics under you know
relative to these these waves
particularly we look at the single cell
activity the single unit activity
and what we found with these uh waves
were is that they were probably
post-inhibitor port stimulation
inhibitory waves so when we took a look
at the spiking activity at the same time
as these inhibitory waves we found that
the spiking activity would increase
for a short bit right after uh
stimulation
but then the inhibitory wave would come
through and actually seem to correspond
with the immediate stop of being of the
spiking activity
you know making us think that these this
is a mechanism of
uh
of actually compensating or
basically a shutoff of over excitability
or a way a homeostatic uh process to be
able to stop you know over spiking or or
over excitation
of course there's huge questions with
regard to this and they an exciting
evidence of investigation that uh a
little malola will be investigating
which is whether when this particular
inhibitory wave shows up
how do these how does this map to
ongoing clinical mapping or such as in
language mapping and whether this wave
could have any correspondence to you
know identifying pathogenic versus
healthy cortex
so therefore this already starts to
reveal an aspect of you know something
as close to mechanism that we otherwise
would not be able to have without these
microelectrodes regarding you know how
stimulation affects the human brain
especially in this clinical domain
of course there's other functions and
other aspects of behavior that you know
that are really important to understand
which is also tracking uh in this
instance sensory motor activity in high
spatial resolution this is work i
entirely done
by
oregon health sciences university and dr
roslyn and team uh in a paper that also
was recently published by young macho
where
we took a look at i mean they took a
look at ongoing motor activity
and what you're going to see in this at
this video is a recording for my 1024
channel grid and
what these arrows and the different
surveys are going to be indicating is is
you know beta waves that are propagating
from different directions such as the uh
sensory motor uh sort of strips
and what happens as a person actually
grips their hand and then releases their
hand
and how it can actually just propagate
across this high resolution grid now
imagine that basically instead of this
1024
grid to be able to record this kind of
activity a lot of the clinical leads are
generally between four to eight contacts
over you know much wider space so this
already
gains a huge amount of information
regarding the the you know intricacies
and the dynamics of how the brain you
know can produce a movement and a
behavior
so this kind of tracking and as well as
a number of different functions that uh
the
young macho and others had actually sort
of uncovered using this kind of like a
thousand channel recordings
could you know open up an entire array
of understanding you know human brain
activity but also brain machine
interfaces in the case of individuals
who are paraplegic
of course there's also an aspect that is
a huge portion of why
and how we uh sort of address these
questions of pathophysiology because an
aspect of this work is you know we are
approaching patients that are undergoing
uh clinical surgery in the first place
and we want to be able to better
understand
the particular reasons that are there
such as epilepsy or tumor and that in
particular has been you know that effort
has been led by dr sydney cash and dr
jimmy yang and dr priya salami here
of understanding and using microscale
electrodes to understand
pathophysiologies particularly epileptic
form activity
in the human brain
because there are certain signatures
there are certain physiological
signatures of of areas or tissue that is
known to um
if you
basically you know known to be able to
correlate to say seizure onset zones or
be near tumor and these particular
neurophysiological signatures are often
sampled at low resolution i showed you
earlier a a image of the clinical lead
it is much larger relative to these
microelectrodes and so the question is
whether or not these microelectrodes
could be able to help us understand
intellectual discharges which are these
large sort of you know spike like things
that are much larger in duration so 250
milliseconds in duration
or high frequency oscillations both of
which have been correlated with areas
that are areas of tissue that are
pathogenic
and so in this paper with that led by
dr
yang the question was whether or not the
identification of the location direction
and propagation of these these
pathogenic signals may be important with
regard to
surgical planning and treatment
so what he was found with this uh a data
set of 31 participants
is that there was actually a propagation
a path that interactive discharges in
particular uh took across the the
electrode array which could only be
sampled using microelectrodes
and that path was repeated there's
actually clusters of activity that would
actually happen over and over again
which again you would not be able to
identify
um this kind of information which you
know because the there are paths
the great part is that means there may
be sources to be able to sort of hunt
back down to and to be able to you know
trace along the
surface of the cortex using the thin
film surface array
the other
discovery he uncovered in this
particular paper was that there were
high frequency oscillation hotspots
there are basically regions of the
cortex that seem to consistently produce
these these little insert buzzes so to
speak
that which you know again could be
localized
to about 200 300 microns in diameter
with across the cortex
sampled using these microelectrodes
and to really kind of convey and
communicate why you know once again why
this scale matters in the same size of
array and this is on this sort of
summary diagram on the right
where you can actually across an in the
array you can detect intellectual
discharges in their propagation you can
identify local hot spots of high
frequency oscillations and we also found
in this the study that there could be
micro seizures which are huge
seizure-like events but only occurring
with a within an area like a surface
area of like a you know radius of 100
microns which is incredible
all that information
is then you know you know with the
microelectrodes and sampled with the
microelectrodes is all is not accessible
using the clinical lead which you know
is shown on the top here as that big
circle
all that information would be summarized
into one single trace which
this already tells us that we gain we
are gaining useful information including
clinically relevant information
with regards to the human brain using
these microelectrodes and the thin film
devices
but of course there's a huge question
which is what could be occurring with a
single unit activity during these events
and
that is an important question with
regard to
understanding what cells are driving
epileptic form activity versus what
cells are not and we had an opportunity
to be able to record in a different case
using the neural pixels
electrodes single unit activity and
identify what's going on with with
single cells relative to interoperable
discharges we found some cells did
actually sort of increase their firing
right at the peak of the interval
discharges other cells were actually
inhibited so this may already start to
uncover sort of cell cell interactions
and dynamics that we otherwise would not
have been able to
uncover using
a larger electrodes or lower resolution
electrodes
so in summary
i hopefully was able to
you know convince you that increased
spatial resolution is
a powerful and useful tool that we can
actually start to use to identify a wide
variety of single cell types
that you know beyond single cells a
variety of neural activities can be
revealed through higher spatial sampling
in their you know social interactions
particularly under uh you know you know
in the aspect of what happens during
stimulation um which is used
therapeutically and you know in the
treatment of a number of disorders but
there's still major questions about what
exactly stimulation is doing with
uh neural activity
of course there's also a we can track
sensory motor activity and look at
behavior and cognition
and
you know a major
direction of this this work is also to
discover single neuron contributions to
pathological activity and
ask whether or not these improvements in
the technology may actually lead to
better clinical outcomes such as
identification of of uh sort of tumor
and tumor infiltration using
electrophysiology at this high micro uh
you know sampling scale
so in the end you know the next big
steps are not just the fact that like i
just laid out several projects which are
major launching grounds for you know you
know years of of you know in fascinating
and an exciting investigation
but
also that
these studies and studies from other
groups have repeatedly shown that higher
resolution approaches especially when
applied to human questions have revealed
important detailed information about
physiology
this has been a major motivation for
several of our publications where we're
not only discussing our findings but
offer advice and lessons learned and
our reason nature neuroscience paper was
a
example of that where we wanted to be
able to communicate what worked what
didn't and what and be able to enable
groups across the you know the
neuroscience community to be able to
sort of uh work in this space
so that more groups could pursue this
line of questioning as well share the
de-identified data on public
data repositories such as dryad and daby
and to push this even further i look
forward to contributing to a massive
shared microscale electrophysiological
data repository such as that we as a
community
can possibly answer fundamental
questions of cognition and address
mechanisms of treatment of
neuropathologies in this incredible era
of neuroscience discovery
and all this would not have been
possible without a huge and massive team
i've highlighted some of the people here
but this has been a true effort of you
know gargantuan proportions and a huge
thanks to the patients who participate
in these studies
they are the heroes of these studies in
that in every single way they actually
their time and their help in this can
allow us to you know lead to new and
better discoveries and hopefully
clinical interventions in all of these
neurophysiological um are
neuropathological
diseases thank you very much
you